[Musique]
c'est une histoire plutôt insolite qui
vient d'être révélée dans la presse une
enseignante accusée d'avoir twarké sur
son élève pour rappel le twerk est une
danse pour le moins suggestive qui
rythme de nombreux soirées endiablées
et il y a quelques jours dans les sols
une enseignante a donc réalisé cette
danse sur les parties intimes de son
élève de saison en lui caressant le
visage choqué la mère de l'adolescent
immédiatement porté plainte contre la
professeure pour attouchement sexuel
mais de son côté l’enseignante
s'est-elle aussi rendue au commissariat
pour dénonciation quel homme muse alors
la prof doit-elle être lourdement
sanctionnée
alors
est-ce que c'était quoi le contexte
gilberté alors c'était un cours de
matière artistique et puis devant
d'autres élèves et d'un coup la
l'enseignante s'est mise à twerké de
manière suggestive si vous voulez ce
serait mise avec le conditionnel
d'accord Beney merci pour l'action face
à l'adolescent et du coup les autres
élèves ont été choqués donc ça a été
rapporté au proviseur et parfois on
souligne que l'éducation nationale ne
fait rien bah là le proviseur il a
enquêté pendant 15 jours et 15 jours
après il a appelé les parents en disant
les faits sont avérés et l'Académie
explique que les faits sont avérées elle
a bien fait ça alors elle elle crie à la
vengeance parce qu'elle aurait voulu
qu'un autre adolescent ami de celui
devant lequel elle a twerké par son
conseil de discipline elle dit que c'est
une vengeance ah oui oui donc elle a
porté plainte pour diffamation alors moi
avec plaisir
les parents sont portés on n'a pas
vraiment le symbole d'histoire parce que
là tu dis ça de façon en disant il y a
une vérité qui a été révélée exactement
le cas pour l'instant on ne sait pas
encore
elle a porté plainte pour dénonciation
calomnieuse elle dit effectivement que
l'élève ment parce qu'il cherche à se
venger d'un conseil de discipline
qu'elle a réclamé pour un autre élève
mais parce que cette autre élève
aurais-tu une arme blanche dans son sac
à dos donc on a tous les toutes les
histoires ça semble plus complexe que ça
c'est pour ça que j'ai mis non c'est pas
possible elle l'aurait bloqué contre
l'armoire
possible il faut une cohérence si les
filles ils sont avérées pourquoi parce
que ça serait une femme qui Twer ça
serait pas une agression sexuelle c'est
dégueulasse ça n'a rien à voir quel
contexte qu'elle voulait vous n'avez
bien sûr mais les filles qui sont
décrits par le jeune homme ou elle se
serait plaqué contre lui qu'elle lui
aurait touché les parties intimes etc
c'est une agression sexuelle c'est sûr
moi la vérité je vous dire je vous avais
été je voulais pas vous raconter ça je
voulais vous raconter ça j'étais avec
une chroniqueuse qui me disait voilà moi
ma spécialité c'est les boulettes et
elle est venue comme ça
vous avez compris que c'était Valérie
Benaim
moi je malaxe les boulettes je lui dis
écoute Valérie je mange pas de sopalin
j'ai appelé la sécurité moteur est
arrivé et motard il fait et toi
[Applaudissements]
sur une élève de 16 ans oui si on avait
changé
la danse c'est qu'ils n'ont toujours pas
interrogé les autres élèves qui étaient
présents dans la salle quand même aucune
vidéo aussi on a rien en fait
c'est une prof elle va vraiment twerker
1000 vidéos déjà sur internet c'est sûr
et certain
c'est pas grave il faut préciser que la
famille de l'adolescent n'a pas demandé
de changement d'affectation donc elle
continue de donner des cours dans
l'établissement ils ont pas voulu que ça
aille plus loin ils ont porté plainte
mais bon
mais non mais je ne peux pas croire
qu'une qu'une enseignante est pris ce
risque là devant une classe entière
excusez-moi c'est quand même l'air
d'être un peu spécial parce qu'on parle
quand même de toi d'un côté et d'armes
blanches dans un sac de l'autre moi je
pense vraiment que c'est une vengeance
elle n'aurait pas pris ce risque là pour
l'instant je suis plutôt du côté de
l'enseignant évidemment
j'ai une tu peux lui parler c'est des
règles ici tomber tu lèves la main s'il
vous plaît voilà vas-y essaie
[Rires]
un peu comme Guillaume c'est vrai que si
on inverse le truc mais d'abord on dit
que il y a pas de preuve et je me dis 16
ans et les lourdes sanctions la phrase
c'est les lourdes sanctions c'est la
lourde sanction qui me fait qui m'embête
si on dit oui un rappel elle se fait
convoquer je veux bien si ça avait mais
la lourde sanction pour un toit qui sont
priorité direct oui parce que bonjour
s'il y a une coalition des élèves on
s'est en général que les élèves sont pas
super fan des professeurs ça arrive
souvent moi je le sais quand j'étais
petit c'était souvent ça parce que moi
j'étais très proche de la prof parce que
justement j'avais une mauvaise note donc
je la voilà et donc du coup je veux dire
c'est que peut-être qu'il y a une
coalition des élèves qui fréquent en
sorte voilà et puis savoir un problème
il y a pas de vidéo est-ce que je disais
il y aura peut-être des caméras de
surveillance de surveillance donc on
répète on n'a pas le droit d'avoir des
cases des caméras de surveillance dans
une classe c'est compliqué tu es content
de ton intervention
tu te mettrai une note aujourd'hui
il y a de la véracité parce que moi j'ai
eu c'est bien c'est un vécu ça fait quoi
toi tu as arrêté des colères moi je suis
arrêté très tôt
ah ça se passait mal à l'école en plus
donc je t'ai pas demandé de me raconter
ta vie et moi j'ai fait un bébé Fanta
sur ma chambre puis après j'ai voilà on
a arrêté là
mais après j'allais Europe 1 je vous
attendais c'est vrai
je le rappelle
le con il est encore là
c'est pour ça que j'ai envoyé de
Fontenay
je te trouvais que tu avais un truc ah
c'est gentil je me suis pas trompé
il avait donc
pour ta raison sur rien comme d'habitude
ça me trompe parce que tu es pour la
justice expéditrice ça veut dire que
cette pauvre on ne sait pas on a on fait
pas vraiment d'enquête on n'a pas encore
écouté les autres élèves en revanche moi
je pense que il y a pas de twerk en
aucun cas à l'école avec un prof bien
sûr un prof n'a pas à twerker point en
fait bien sûr si c'est des cours de
danse